Do we chose what we eat or do the bacteria
living in our gut decide?
Hello everyone!
I'm Reina and this is DNews.
The friendly bacteria that live within us
may not only be affecting food cravings but
also our moods.
Research has shown that this may even lead
to a causal relationship with obesity.
Researchers from UC San Francisco, Arizona
State University and University of New Mexico
have concluded that microbes do in fact influence
eating habits and food choices to favor consumption
of specific nutrients that the microbes themselves
thrive best on.
In the past it was thought that microbes passively
took in whatever nutrients we ingested.
Bacterial species have different nutrients
they thrive off of; some favor sugars, others
can favor starches, fats, et cetera.
And because the human gut is directly linked
to the immune system, nervous system, and
endocrine system, the community of microbes
that live within you influence your eating
choices!
The gut microbiome does this by releasing
signaling molecules, which allow the cells
to perceive and respond correctly to the microenvironment.
Then, those signals go on to influence our
physiologic and behavioral responses.
The Director of Human and Social Evolution
at UCSF, explains "Microbes have the capacity
to manipulate behavior and mood through altering
the neural signals in the vagus nerve, changing
taste receptors, producing toxins to make
us feel bad, and releasing chemical rewards
to make us feel good."
For example, in mice particular strands of
bacteria can increase anxious behavior.
In a nutshell, the bacteria didn’t like
what the mice were eating so they chemically
signaled a reaction that would cause the mice
to feel anxiety.
The mice would then correlate the food to
be causing the anxiety and cease to continue
eating it.[a]
On a larger scale, clinical trials discovered
that drinking a probiotic containing Lactobacillus
casei (kay see ee), which can relieve gastrointestinal
pathogenic bacterial disease, actually improved
low moods.
Dr. Carlo Maley, director of the UCSF Center
for Evolution and Cancer explains
"Bacteria within the gut are manipulative.
There is a diversity of interests represented
in the microbiome, some aligned with our own
dietary goals, and others not."
The speed with which the microbiome can change
may be encouraging to those who seek to improve
health by altering microbial populations.
This usually happens through food and supplement
choices, by ingesting specific bacterial species
in the form of probiotics, or by killing targeted
species with antibiotics.
According to researchers, optimizing the balance
among bacterial species in our gut may allow
us to lead less obese and healthier lives.
Researchers[b] proposed further studies to
investigate the power microbes hold over us.
They say that "Targeting the microbiome could
open up possibilities for preventing a variety
of disease from obesity and diabetes to cancers
of the gastro-intestinal tract.
We are only beginning to scratch the surface
of the importance of the microbiome for human
health.”
What do you think?
Would you get a gut microbe transplant in
hopes of improving your health?
Tell us in the comment section down below,
don’t forget to give that like button some
love and subscribe if you haven’t already!
For more of my videos head on over to sourcefed
and sourcefednerd!
Thanks for tunin in!